je remercie d'être en direct sur rt
france alors c'est la première fois
qu'un secrétaire d'état américain se
rend au surinam et le guyana
le principal objectif de ce déplacement
c'est de vente et les entreprises
américaines sur la concurrence chinoise
selon vous pas vraiment je ne pense pas
c'est surtout politique
à la base il faut savoir que
contrairement à ce qui se passe
généralement d'ailleurs lors des visites
du c'est-à-dire d'état pompéo
généralement des communiqués qui sont
publiés dans le département d'état et là
bizarrement les communiqués ont pas été
très précis sur leur contenu
donc l'agenda de la vie de pompéo au
suriname et a fortiori au guyana n'est
pas clair donc on peut supposer que la
forme rejoignent en partie le font
certaines questions qui vont être
discutés concerne plutôt les aspects
politiques et la nouvelle relation que
bombay au souhaite entretenir avec le
nouveau président du guyana
sachant que l'administration américaine
a soutenu le pbp donc le parti de du
nouveau président sur les questions
strictement politique donc le guyana une
frontière à l'est de du venezuela et le
david granger l'ancien président avait
souhaité rester neutre dans la querelle
entre maduro et le président-élu
autoproclamé juan garrido soutenu par
les américains
donc une des questions qui va sans doute
être évoquée c'est celle de la lah pour
l'aiguiller luena de rejoindre le fameux
groupe de lima c'est à dire tous les
pays d'amérique latine qui sont
favorables à juan garrido
ce que n'avait pas fait
son prédécesseur le prédécesseur avait
voulu rester dans une certaine
neutralité dès lors que le venezuela
conteste une partie de ce parti des
droits sur le territoire et la zone
maritime du guyana et la historiquement
il faut remonter à 1966 et à
l'indépendance du guyana ancienne
colonie britannique
les britanniques avaient accordé alors
au venezuela
la reconnaissance de leurs
revendications territoriales sur les
deux tiers du guyana avec dans le
prolongement des revendications
maritimes salon sur ce point il faut
quand même préciser que quand bien même
le venezuela obtiendrait ses droits ce
qui est hors de question évidemment les
gisements qui ont été découverts l'ont
été au sud-est de la zone maritime du
ghana et donc serait théoriquement hors
de portée des revendications terrestres
et maritimes du venezuela
il y avait des visées visées politiques
comme comme vous venez de l'expliquer il
ya sûrement aussi un objectif économique
puisqu'on sait que la chine veut
investir massivement dans dans le pays
dans ces pays via une nouvelle route de
la soie
est-ce qu'elle a les moyens qu'on craint
c'est que concurrencé par dont les états
unis justement sur leur propre continent
trahi mais il faut un soutien politique
infirmant le brésil du temps de 2,2 du
président lula et ensuite de de la
présidente
jusqu'à 1 pt qui a été évincé du pouvoir
s'était rapproché de la chine avec
bolton à rome où il est clair qu'au
contraire c'est la relation avec les
états unis qui va dominer donc dans la
visite de pompey aujourd'hui vous avez
deux pays la colombie qui sont infidèles
et soutient inconditionnel des états
unis depuis des décennies et le brésil
qui vient changé de présidente
en 2009 et fin 2018 et donc le guyana
est il à surinam dans cette perspective
sont des nouveaux arrivants d'où la
visite de pomper ou sur les aspects
commerciaux
il est clair que les questions
pétrolières peuvent être importantes
puisque du fait des discussions suite
aux résultats des élections
un projet d'exxon sur un nouveau
gisement lexon en fait et développe déjà
de grosses difficilement au guyana lisa
vise à deux et un troisième gisement
était bloqué enfin le développement
était bloquée parce que précisément les
autorisations gouvernementales devraient
pas été données et du fait du flou
politique suite aux élections ils
pouvaient pas être donnée donc l'arrivée
de deux du nouveau président va
certainement développer débloquer la
situation et permettre à exxon
d'exploiter ou de développement de 400
troisième gros gisement au guyana merci
beaucoup monsieur monsieur lopez d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de géo place ces
spécialistes des enjeux énergétiques